[applause]
[applause
] we have this long long
stage [ __ ] tyrant just one [ __ ] from
her there are no words you understand there are no words for
this to pronounce
I woke up from the fact that but in it my mother
woke up there was smoke everywhere there was just dust
we hid the pantry thought  we are being
captured coming in Russian types of doors
it turned out not we got out we looked at us it
turns out the stairs are no longer there everything
is on fire we don’t know what to do you run
to the balcony
there we tried what to wear started
climbing over the balconies and went down from
that entrance
now we are trying to give something to us  the
firefighters thing,
I saw,
as it were, a
smoke trajectory falls here, then
an explosion and a
neighboring house, I was there on the balcony and
heard explosions and smoke went
in this one and then ran here, one person died there,
carefully,
an elderly 70 years old
, the Ministry of Emergency Situations came, they thought the girl said that
her pulse is still there they came Yura
touched already says